and Miami forgot I was a couple years
ago so I didn't kiss just would not be
the word but I was working there with
Fox when Hurricane George hit the keys I
just thought this is kind of funny they
evacuated the keys and everybody left
except for I've been through two
hurricanes I was in hurricane Carla when
I was a kid in Houston and I was really
excited during hurricane time you know
because if out there in the Gulf and
it's dangerous and I was like this is
cool till [ __ ] started hitting our house
I was like [ __ ] this but anyway they
evacuate the keys and everybody leaves
except for one guy who's going to stay
there and tie himself to a tree on the
beach to prove a point and the point was
he said that at 53 years of age he was
in good enough physical condition to
withstand the wind and the rain from a
forestry hurricane all right let me
explain something to you
it isn't that the wind is blowing
it's what the wind is blowing
if you get hit with a Volvo it doesn't
really matter how many sit-ups you did
that morning
[Applause]